- So unlike many of you here,
I am not technology savvy person.
However, I'm just very practical person.
So today I simply would like to share
one of the features I found
very useful and practical.
That is Canvas Modules.
Okay, so builders often time to say
don't even try to build a
house without blueprints, okay?
So blueprints, the
general definition of it
is a set of construction
or working drawings
that define all the constructions specs
of a residential house such as dimensions,
materials, layouts, installation
method and techniques.
So in the same context,
I think teaching and learning modules
means detailed lesson plans
that presents assessments,
assignments, projects, homework,
learning activities,
presentations, resources,
even timeline and expected
or final outcomes.
So basically you can put every ingredients
into this Canvas Modules
about your course.
Therefore I think Canvas
Modules merely functions
as blueprints of your course curriculum.
As you see here, you can
organize your materials
by each category.
So even resources, you can
put all course resources here.
And this is the big categories.
You can organize your course contents
by unit and time or both.
So each of big categories
can have more detailed ingredients.
So you can put, as I said here,
assignment, presentations, or
test quizzes and everything.
So again, why do I use Canvas Modules?
I said it's easy to use,
and it's a clear communication tool,
communication tool
between me and my students
and my colleagues and my teaching fellows.
Especially for multi-section
and team-teaching setting.
Also this is great tool
for course organize.
So I am course head and
coordinator of the program,
so through these Canvas Modules
I can really keep curricular consistency
and pedagogical alignment.
And also great tool for training my TFs,
and often times they call,
what do I teach, and how do I teach,
and I clearly directed them
to these Canvas Modules.
So through these Canvas Modules, again,
I can keep my course very
transparent to my students
and colleagues and teaching fellows.
So after all,
the modules can function
as your course portfolio.
So these are the frequent
asked questions I get.
I'm sure you guys get
these kind of questions
from your students or teaching
fellows or colleagues.
So where should I upload my assignments?
Students still ask the questions.
Surprisingly, some of
students don't even read
the course syllabus until
the end of a semester.
What should I cover
next week in section X?
TFs can ask these questions.
And then what do you teach in this course?
Well, often times it's
your colleagues ask you.
You can now answer by
saying I teach very well,
and I do a lot of different
stuff in my class.
Simply visualize what
you do with your students
in the course through Canvas Modules.
These questions go on and on and on,
so now you know my answer
is, you can answer for me,
through Canvas Modules,
that is correct, yes.
So this is great tool
and very easy to utilize.
So please use them as much as possible
and I get great support from Christine
and Kimberly and all campus colleagues.
That's it.
(applause)
Too early?
- [Woman] Questions?
- Questions?
How many of you use Canvas Modules?
Ah, see.
You can add some anecdote, yeah?
- [Woman] Do your students ever,
at the beginning of the term
or even throughout the term,
forget that you're using the modules?
I know this is something
that I struggle with.
Like, I have to tell
my students repeatedly,
over and over again.
Oh where is this resource?
It's in the module, look in the modules.
How do you combat that in class?
- So beginning of the semester,
I clearly say everything
is in the modules,
and then I enforce them every day,
did you check Canvas Modules?
And then, first week or so,
they all get settled, yeah.
- [Woman] I also find it helpful
that if you don't just
put it in the module,
but if you, thank you, if you assign...
Like for example, for mine,
I organize everything by chapter.
So they will look for that particular item
in modules in that chapter.
But otherwise, you're right.
I mean, I can't keep my quizzes in quizzes
because nobody will find them
or else they will take the wrong one,
of course, we know that problem.
But the linear organization week by week
I highly recommend organizing
either on calendar basis,
like how your syllabus
runs week one, week two,
or in our case, it's by chapter.
- [Woman] Another option is to use pages.
On the first page you
will just have a link
to the right modules, that
way they won't be confused.
- Any other questions or comments?
All right, thank you.
- [Timberley] Great, thank you so much.